it's one of the most iconic images of
the troubles
ira leader joe mccann wielding a gun on
the streets of belfast
he's reported to have killed 15 soldiers
but the 24 year old was unarmed when
shot dead by british troops in april
1972.
his family had waited nearly 49 years
for a trial
that collapsed in a week
the judge was right when he used the
word appalling
to describe the failure of the state at
all levels
in relation to the murder of joe mccann
the ruc failed the criminal justice
field
not only in this case but in the case
of many other families this ruling does
not acquit the state
of murder this ruling does not mean that
juma khan
was not murdered by the british army
this trial has heard very clear evidence
that jimmy khan was murdered
by the british army he was shot in the
back
whilst unarmed from a distance of 40
meters
posing no threat the accused identified
only as soldiers a
and c were charged with murder the case
collapsed when statements they'd given
were ruled inadmissible
the judge said it was remarkable that
the soldiers had never been arrested and
questioned by police
about the shooting of joe mccann in this
street in 1972
statements they'd given to the army
shortly afterwards
and to the historical investigations
team in 2010
were precluded because they'd not been
given under caution
veterans have called for an end to
historical prosecutions
former armed forces minister johnny
mercer who resigned over the issue last
week was back in belfast supporting them
he says this case raises huge questions
the judge has been very very clear about
the credibility and the admissibility of
the evidence
and in the meantime these two soldiers
lives have been ruined over the last 10
years i think
it's deeply unfair it's unfair on all
sides it only seems to make the legal
teams happy who make a lot of public
money from this
you know the prime minister promised to
introduce legislation to curb it he
needs to get on with it and do it
the past is never far from the present
here but the passage of time makes
historical prosecutions
almost impossible cold comfort for
families demanding justice
david blevins sky news in belfast